At the end of the previous video we chose a metric which we thought would be
a good way to quantify the question when will my service deck arrive?
We ended up going with the technician's actual reported arrival time at
the customer's home.
Now to proceed we have to find a way to turn that
question into a rigorous statistical inference problem such as point estimation,
confidence sets, classification or parameter estimation.
For example, the problem could be cast as a classification problem in which we
attempt to predict if the technician will arrive before noon or after noon.
At the complete other end of the spectrum,
we could create a regression estimator which predicts a precise time of arrival.
Both of these have advantages and disadvantages.
Now before telling you how we approach this problem.
We would love to know if you cast this as a classification or
a regression problem.
Why or why not?
Like the previous assessment, please share your thoughts with your
fellow students in the forum post linked in the instructor comment below.